if you want to hear how the original
1933 Invisible Man secretly appears in
this 2020 reimagining that stick around
to the end of this video uh yeah I'm
over here our story begins at 3:42 in
the morning as Cecilia wakes up to try
to escape from Adrian's prison like the
state one of the first things she does
is turn in security camera towards the
bedroom so that she can keep an eye on
him rather than the other way around
I think it's kind of interesting how she
has this strategy of using Adrian's
technology against him from the very
beginning and it isn't until later until
she realizes how to fully take advantage
of that idea two weeks after escaping
she is still super paranoid and at that
point we don't know why we don't know
that
Adrian was this optics technology
mastermind but there are clues like
Cecilia painting over her webcam the
mechanical sound she hears at night and
later flashes of light which we find out
to be Adrian taking photos of her part
of his plan to make her go crazy she
also receives mail which informs her of
Adrian's will reading at an address that
nobody is supposed to know that she's at
which doesn't make sense until we find
out that Adrian is using the suits to
stalk her Adrian's full name by the way
is Adrian Griffin which is a slight nod
to Jack Roth the scientist who learned
how to make himself invisible and became
the original Invisible Man
Cecilia's name on the other hand is a
feminine version of the name cecil which
is derived from the latin word meaning
blind seeing as she can't see adrian
there are also a lot of examples of the
camera angle suddenly cutting to a wide
shot taken from another room and i think
that this is supposed to be Adrian's
point of view as he's sneaking around
the house and spying on her and one more
note on those mechanical sounds that she
hears the Invisible Man doesn't really
have a signature sound like some of the
other classic Universal Monsters I mean
you can't have him growl like the wolf
man or hiss like Dracula because that
would be ridiculous so it's cool how
they found a sound that fits the sci-fi
of reimagining of the story and also is
still really creepy when Cecilia is
escaping we see her Cal Poly
architecture sweater and later she
interviews for a job at an architectural
firm the characters have fitting career
choices for their roles in the story
architecture represents privacy it's the
idea of putting up walls and shielding
yourself from the gaze of the outside
world an optics technology represents
the invasion of privacy people like
Adrian are suppliers for paparazzi and
in our world today technology companies
are seen as leashes for data and are
often criticized for their misleading
privacy policies so there's some social
commentary
which if you're gonna remake a classic
movie and bring it back into modern
times it's always nice to see that
there's actually a reason for that
update
after Cecilia escaped she's staying at
James's house and I noticed him wearing
a shirt that says prestige records 1949
the year may be a reference to the
release day of the Invisible Man appears
which was a Japanese adaptation of HG
Wells novel The Invisible Man which is
what the original film was based
[Music]
it's also a Japanese restaurant where
Cecilia and Emily later have their
reconciliation meeting though that may
be a coincidence it's hard to say for
sure but there's a bigger reference to
the original Invisible Man nested inside
of James's house Cecilia is sleeping in
the same room as the daughter Sydney and
her dream is to go to fashion school so
her room is filled with clothing of her
own design as you might expect there's a
mannequin in the room and it's wearing
this one hat and if I remember correctly
it's wearing sunglasses too this is a
big Easter egg because the mannequin is
basically dressed up like the Invisible
Man from the original movie it actually
kind of confused me when I first saw it
on screen because I thought we were
seeing the monster for the first time
and it took me a minute to realize that
it was an actual mannequin I'm sure most
audiences who aren't familiar with the
1933 film didn't have that issue though
there would be another big reference to
that original movie later but in the
meantime there were some more
contemporary references as well the
blanket pulling scene pays homage to the
conjurer and when Cecilia spreads coffee
beans all over the floor to try to catch
the invisible man's footsteps it's very
reminiscent of paranormal activity where
the character Katie spreads flour on the
floor to try to record the invisible
entities footsteps
[Music]
I think that the director of the
Invisible Man Leigh Whannell put in
these connections because he's friends
with James Wan who directed the
conjuring and Oren Peli who directed
Paranormal Activity in fact when ELLs
directorial debut was insidious chapter
three excellent movie and that film was
produced by Juan and Pelle
Adrian messes with Cecilia's life and
makes her question her own sanity things
get really crazy when he drugs her and
she passes out during her job interview
she ends up in the hospital and in the
hallway there's another patient who's
completely wrapped in bandages which is
a clever reference to once again the
original Invisible Man where he hides
his invisibility by entirely wrapping
himself up in bandages the scene where
he reveals himself or I guess does the
opposite of that shows himself removing
these bandages and is considered to be
the most iconic scene in the movie after
Cecelia confirms that Adrian is stalking
her by finding the phone knife and
photographs in the Attic she goes back
to Adrian's fortress of a house and
strangely the dog is still there another
clue that he's still living there I
imagine when he faked his suicide he
left the dog to his brother as not to
raise suspicion and then had him
returned to the house where nobody would
find out that he's still living there
because of the huge walls that surround
the place speaking of the brother let's
fast forward a little bit to when
Cecilia is in the psych ward after being
framed for killing her sister by Adrian
his brother informed Cecilia that he'll
be withholding the money from the will
because she committed a crime and she
basically figures out that he's in on
the whole operation she calls him a
jellyfish version of Adrian because he
has no spine there's a Seymour son
jellyfish Seymour guts in
eleven-year-old kid no but okay maybe
it's just my email Abraham Lincoln side
chilling but the more I think about it
the more I think that this could
actually be a reference to that song by
brand-new I mean think about it the main
course of the song is everyone's caught
on to everything you do
[Music]
adrian has manipulated cecilia for a
long time but nobody knew the extent of
how badly he controlled her until she
escaped and exposed his behavior then
there's also that line
don't apologize I hope you choke and die
and at the end of the movie adrian tries
to make up with her and she ends up
using the invisibility suit to cut his
throat and he chokes and dies so there's
that Leigh Whannell is from Australia so
I don't know how familiar he would be
with the Long Island emo scene but one
thing he's probably familiar with is
aquatic life because Australia is
regarded as one of the world's top scuba
destinations
I noticed later in the movie that Sydney
has a jellyfish shirt and that got me
thinking again about Cecilia calling
Adrienne's brother a jellyfish now in
Australia there's a creature known is
that you're a congi jellyfish and
they're considered dangerous because
they're venomous and they can make
themselves invisible or at least very
close to invisible and this fits
perfectly because Adrian's brother is
later discovered to also be using the
invisibility suit to help Adrian with
his scheme he's a toxic person with the
ability to go invisible in this case
instead of divers off the coast being
the victims it's a seemingly endless
amount of cops who just seem to keep
spawning and getting killed in that one
hallway what's going on over here well
are they in the room how you gonna spawn
in this inside the roof yeah so the
story ends with as I mentioned Cecilia
killing Adrian claiming it wasn't her
and getting James to go along with her
stories somewhat reluctantly
she steals the invisibility suit for
herself because I guess these things
have really good battery life and in
doing so seems to set up the sequel The
Invisible Woman I'm guessing that she's
gonna start using the suit for herself
and slowly start to become the villain
and James is gonna have to be the one to
try to stop her and I'm all for it I
think there's a lot more that can be
covered with this concept and with smart
characters like these it should be a lot
of fun of course I'll be covering it
here on Suzy's world if that does happen
but until then click the video on the
left and go ahead and subscribe to see
ZZZ world for new Horrors every week
ring that DEATH BATTLE for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Applause]
[Music]